Bonjour à tous,
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un sujet
un peu différent de l'habitude,
on va parler de sciences économiques.
Alors pas tellement pour en évoquer
les grands principes,
d'autres le font déjà, mieux que moi, mais
pour vous raconter une petite anecdote.
Une anecdote qui nous dit des choses
intéressantes
sur le fonctionnement de la science
et son utilisation
pour des décisions politiques.
Ça peut peut-être nous servir
en ce moment.
[Générique]
L'histoire commence en 2010,
à ce moment-là on est en pleine crise
économique et financière,
celle qui a commencé quelques années
plus tôt,
et les gouvernements de tous les pays
se demandent logiquement
comment sortir rapidement et efficacement
de cette crise.
C'est alors que deux économistes
Kenneth Rogoff et Carmen Reinhart
publient un article scientifique
qui va devenir extrêmement influent.
Ces deux-là ne sont pas n'importe qui,
ce sont deux pointures
de l'université de Harvard aux États-Unis
et en plus de ça, ils publient leur article
dans une revue spécialisée
"l'American Economic Review"
qui est une des revues
les plus prisées des chercheurs
en sciences économiques.
On est donc a priori sur du lourd,
l'article en question s'intitule
"Growth in a Time of Debt"
la croissance en temps de dette,
le but de l'article c'est d'analyser le lien
qui peut exister entre la croissance
économique d'un pays
et son niveau d'endettement, c'est-à-dire
la dette publique accumulée par l'état.
Alors pour ça nos deux chercheurs se basent
sur les données économiques
depuis 1946 pour 20 pays occidentaux
les États-Unis, la France, le Portugal,
l’Allemagne, etc.
et ils essaient de voir si, en moyenne,
il existe un lien entre croissance et dette.
Alors la dette dont on parle ce n'est pas
le déficit du budget pour une année donnée,
c'est la dette accumulée au cours du temps,
année après année,
et comme le montant va dépendre évidemment
de la taille de l'économie du pays
on l'exprime généralement en
pourcentage du PIB;
Prenons un exemple: le PIB de l’Allemagne
en 2018 c'était 3344 milliards d'euros
et la dette cumulée c'était 2070 milliards
donc la dette cumulée de l’Allemagne
valait environ 62 % de son PIB.
Alors comme c'est un cumul des dettes
de l'état
qui s'est construit année après année,
ça peut très bien dépasser 100% du PIB,
il n'y a pas de contradiction logique,
en Italie par exemple on est actuellement
autour de 135 % du PIB.
Bon, donc nos deux économistes de Harvard
collectent les valeurs de croissance
et de dettes pour chacun des vingt pays
entre 1946 et 2009.
On imagine qu'ils ont un grand tableau
avec tous ces chiffres
et ils cherchent à voir s'il y a un lien
entre les deux,
et pour ça ils produisent l'analyse
suivante:
Tout d'abord ils vont classer la dette
en quatre cas
pour chaque pays et chaque année,
soit la dette est entre 0 et 30 %,
soit entre 30 et 60%,
entre 60 et 90%, ou bien au-delà de 90%,
et ils regardent la croissance moyenne
observée dans chacun de ces quatre cas.
Et voici ce qu'ils obtiennent:
dans le premier cas, quand on a une dette
en dessous de 30%
on à 4,1% de croissance en moyenne,
dans le second cas, 2,8% de croissance,
un peu moins,
dans le troisième cas entre 60 et 90%
toujours 2,8%,
mais au-delà de 90% de dettes, bim!
pas de croissance du tout en moyenne
même une très légère récession: – 0,1%.
Alors ça c'est très intéressant
ça montre que d'une part
il y aurait un lien entre dette
et croissance,
ce qui, d'un point de vue économique,
paraît tout à fait envisageable,
on peut imaginer qu'à des niveaux
de dette élevés
soient associées des croissances
plus faibles, pourquoi pas?
Mais surtout l'analyse montre qu'il y a
un effet de seuil monstrueux,
avant 90 % de dette en fait ça va,
mais au delà de 90 % de dette la croissance
chute brutalement
il y a un seuil fatidique.
L'existence de ce seuil de 90%,
c'est le principal message
de cet article, et, du fait de la réputation
des auteurs
et de la revue dans laquelle l'article
a été publié,
il a eu semble-t-il une influence
très importante
sur les politiques économiques
qui ont été mises en œuvre à l'époque,
ça se passe en 2010 ça je vous le rappelle.
Derrière les conclusions des deux économistes,
il y a évidemment en filigrane l'idée que,
malgré la crise,
il faudrait absolument éviter
que les dettes publiques atteignent
le seuil fatidique de 90%.
Si l'on suit le raisonnement, dépasser
ce seuil risquerait
de tuer durablement la croissance
et tout devrait donc être fait
pour l'éviter notamment via des politiques
d'austérité financière,
de rigueur budgétaire, d'économies
sur les services publics, etc.
Cette conclusion de l'article
de Reinhart et Rogoff
sur le seuil de 90%, on la retrouve
à de nombreuses reprises
dans les débats économiques et politiques
qui ont existé à l'époque.
En avril 2011 par exemple, 40 sénateurs
américains ont auditionné
les deux économistes et, comme le montrent
ces extraits,
les débats ont tourné notamment autour
du fameux seuil de 90%.
Plus près de chez nous le commissaire
européen à l'économie
Olli Rehn écrira aux ministres des finances
de l'union:
le ministre des finances britannique
déclarait lui aussi à la même époque:
dans le monde anglophone la conclusion
de Reinhart et Rogoff
a fait l'objet d'articles dans
"The Economist" le "New York Times"
le "Wall Street journal"
le "Washington Post" etc.
Dans les milieux universitaires, l'article
a eu aussi une influence énorme,
d'après le site Google Scholar
il a été cité à ce jour
plus de 3300 fois dans des travaux
scientifiques .
Alors le seul souci de cette histoire, vous
l'avez compris dès le titre de la vidéo,
c'est que les conclusions de cet article
si influent se basaient
sur un calcul fait avec Excel,
calcul qui contenait une grosse faute
de frappe dans une des formules.
L'histoire de la découverte de cette erreur
est assez intéressante,
elle commence tardivement, 3 ans plus tard,
en 2013
quand un étudiant en économie Thomas Herndon
a un devoir à faire,
il étudie à l'université du Massachusetts
à Amherst, pas très loin de Harvard,
et ses profs ont posé un exercice
en apparence classique:
prendre un article économique de son choix
et essayer d'en reproduire les résultats.
Thomas Herndon décide alors de choisir
l'article si influent de Reinhart et Rogoff,
et commence à essayer de trouver les données
et refaire leur analyse.
Mais impossible de reproduire
leurs conclusions.
Il en parle à ses profs qui lui disent
que quand même
ça ne devrait pas être bien difficile,
les données sont facilement disponibles,
c'est juste faire des moyennes,
ça devrait pas être bien dur.
Mais non, rien à faire ils ne trouve pas
les mêmes chiffres que Reinhart et Rogoff.
Grâce au soutien de ses profs qui commencent
aussi à avoir des doutes,
notre étudiant écrit alors aux deux
pointures de Harvard
pour leur demander les détails
de leurs calculs
Reinhart et Rogoff envoient alors
une feuille Excel
contenant les données utilisées
et l'analyse qu'ils ont faite.
Et là, notre étudiant découvre
trois problèmes:
Le premier c'est que les deux économistes
de la Harvard ont calculé les moyennes
d'une façon assez bizarre, ça n'est pas
mathématiquement faux
mais c'est assez étrange puisque ça donne
des poids différents
à chaque pays d'une façon qui est
un peu aléatoire.
Par exemple avec leur façon de faire
les moyennes,
certaines années de la Nouvelle-Zélande
ont un impact énorme sur le résultat,
bien plus important que par exemple,
celles du Royaume Uni.
Deuxième problème les économistes de Harvard
n'ont pas utilisé dans leur analyse,
certaines données apparemment disponibles
notamment celles qui concernaient
le Canada, la Nouvelle-Zélande
et l'Australie avant 1950.
des périodes, justement, de forte
croissance pour ces pays
malgré une dette supérieure à 100%.
Difficile de savoir s'il s'agit d'un oubli,
d'une exclusion justifiée
ou carrément d'une magouille, à aucun moment
dans leur article
Reinhart et Rogoff n'ont mentionné
ces exclusions.
Et enfin, troisième problème
le plus spectaculaire,
il y avait une grosse boulette dans
une formule du fichier Excel.
Pour faire le calcul final celui qui donne
les chiffres qui ont été publiés
et que j'ai mentionnés Reinhart et Rogoff
ont fait une moyenne
qui oubliait complètement l'Australie,
l'Autriche, la Belgique,
le Canada et le Danemark, les cinq premiers
pays par ordre alphabétique.
La raison on la voit sur cette capture
d'écran du fichier Excel
obtenu par le journaliste Mike Konczal,
elle montre clairement l'erreur:
une moyenne qui ne porte que sur 15 pays
parmi les 20,
probablement une formule pas mise à jour
ou bien mal étirée sur les cellules.
Au total ce qu'a montré notre étudiant
et qui a été publié
dans un article qu'il a écrit avec ses profs,
c'est que, si on corrige ces trois erreurs,
le résultat change drastiquement.
Voici une comparaison avant après,
on a donc le taux de croissance moyen
dans les quatre cas, moins de 30 % de dette,
30-60, 60-90, et au delà de 90%.
Pour les trois premiers groupes,
après correction
on retrouve des chiffres analogues à ceux
qu'avaient Reinhart et Rogoff:
Mais pour le dernier groupe, les dettes
au-delà de 90%,
on trouve 2,2% de croissance et pas -0,1%
comme affirmé initialement par
les deux auteurs de Harvard.
Une sacrée différence quand même, alors
certes, on a toujours un effet général
qui est que des niveaux de dette plus élevés
sont associés
à des croissances légèrement plus faibles,
mais le message central,
le seuil fatidique de 90%, disparaît
complètement.
Alors que, rappelons-le, ce seuil
un peu magique a semble-t-il
été largement évoqué pour justifier
des politiques d'austérité
aux État-Unis et en Europe, à cause
d'une erreur Excel stupide
qu'il a fallu 3 ans pour débusquer.
Alors au passage les deux économistes
de Harvard ont, évidemment,
à peine reconnu leur erreur
du bout des lèvres,
en disant que ça changeait pas
leurs conclusions!
Cette histoire semblant tellement incroyable,
j'ai voulu creuser un peu les chiffres
pour voir ce qu'il y avait derrière.
Bon, déjà j'ai lu l'article d'origine,
il est assez court, ça se lit bien
et sans être un expert en économétrie
je l'ai trouvé
étonnamment pauvre sur le plan statistique,
il y a juste des moyennes,
même pas mention d'un écart type et
je parle même pas
d'un test statistique pour savoir si
c'est significatif.
Quand on connaît les standards
de publication en la matière,
y compris en sciences économiques,
ça m'a un peu surpris.
Je me suis demandé comment ça avait
pu être publié
dans ce qui est quasiment LA revue
de référence en économie
Et j'ai fini par trouver la réponse.
Cet article n'a pas suivi le processus
habituel,
celui de l'évaluation par les pairs.
J'ai parlé de ce concept dans ma vidéo sur
"comment lire une étude".
Quand des chercheurs, de n'importe
quelle discipline,
écrivent un article scientifique
pour rapporter leur découverte,
cet article est normalement soumis
à une relecture
par d'autres chercheurs du domaine,
dont le travail est de vérifier
que l'article respecte notamment les exigences
de qualité pour être publié.
Mais manifestement pour le numéro
de l'American Economic Review
dans laquelle cet article est paru,
il n'y a pas eu de processus formalisé
de relecture par les pairs,
en gros on a fait confiance aux auteurs
sur la base de leur pedigree.
Pour comprendre mieux ce qui se cachait
derrière ces croissances moyennes
calculées par les uns et les autres,
eh ben j'ai voulu moi-même voir les données
de mes propres yeux
et je vais vous montrer quelques analyses
simples qu'on peut faire.
Alors les données sont disponibles,
je vous mettrai les liens en description
et j'ai ici un tableau avec pour chaque
ligne un pays, une année
et les deux valeurs correspondantes de dette
et de croissance, en pourcentage du PIB;
Il y a environ 1200 lignes, on a une 60aine
d'années pour chacun des 20 pays.
Pour commencer on peut déjà faire
tout simplement un graphique
qui montre la croissance en fonction
de la dette
pour chacune de ces lignes de données,
voilà ce qu'on obtient:
On peut zoomer un peu sur la zone
qui nous intéresse,
mais ce qu'on voit c'est que globalement,
bah c'est le bordel!
Il y en a partout, très loin d'un lien
mécanique, automatique, absolu
entre la dette et la croissance et ça,
ça n'a rien de choquant,
c'est normal, la croissance d'un pays
dépend de tout un tas de facteurs,
pas seulement le niveau de la dette,
mais du coup présenter juste
des moyennes par tranches, sans évoquer
la dispersion des données,
eh bien ça donne l'impression
que le lien est beaucoup plus fort
qu'il ne l'est réellement.
Alors malgré tout, en regardant bien
le graphique,
on peut deviner un petit effet
avec un peu moins de croissance
pour les dettes plus élevées.
Si on veut quantifier ça plus précisément
on peut faire par exemple
une analyse de régression linéaire,
c'est très simple
et on trouve le résultat suivant:
il y a en effet un lien,
c'est un lien significatif statistiquement,
c'est pas juste dû au hasard
et le coefficient montrent que 10%
de dette en plus est associé
en moyenne à 0,18% de croissance en moins.
Donc l'effet moyen semble exister,
c'est une corrélation,
on ne sait pas a priori s'il y a causalité
dans un sens, dans l'autre,
ou si c'est plus compliqué, mais un point
important
c'est que cet effet n'explique qu'une toute
petite partie de la croissance.
Pour quantifier ça, on parle de la variance
expliquée c'est-à-dire:
quelle proportion de la variabilité
des données est expliquée
par notre facteur, ici la dette.
C'est le fameux R² que les gens utilisent
parfois à tort et à travers dans Excel
ici le R² est de 0,04 c'est pas beaucoup,
ça veut dire que le facteur dette
explique
seulement 4 % de la variabilité
de la croissance.
On peut essayer d'aller plus loin
et chercher d'éventuels effets
non linéaires et ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il n'y a pas du tout
de seuil fatidique ni à 90% ni ailleurs,
si on a un petit truc c'est peut-être,
plutôt autour de 30-40 %,
où on a un léger changement de pente.
On peut même calculer que si on se limite
aux données entre 30 et 150 % de dette,
le lien entre croissance et dette pourrait
disparaître complètement,
Bref on pourrait s'amuser longtemps
à faire des analyses avec ces données.
Je vais m'arrêter là, ça n'est pas
mon domaine d'expertise
et d'autres l'ont évidemment fait depuis
de façon carrée.
Mais un dernier calcul quand même.
Évidemment si je découpe mes données
en quatre groupes de dette
comme dans l'article, et que je calcule
les moyennes
je retrouve les chiffres de l'article
corrigés par les chercheurs
de l'université du Massachussetts,
bonne nouvelle!
Et avec ça je veux illustrer
un truc crucial
qui ne concerne pas seulement
la recherche en économie,
c'est l'importance pour les chercheurs
de publier
les données complètes et les codes
de leurs analyses.
Dans plusieurs disciplines scientifiques
on a assisté ces derniers temps
à ce qu'on appelle une "crise
de reproductibilité",
c'est-à-dire que certaines découvertes publiées
par des chercheurs
n'arrivent pas à être répliquées, répétées
par d'autres chercheurs du domaine
donc forcément ça jette un doute
sur les conclusions initiales.
On comprend que dans certains cas ça puisse
être difficile
de reproduire correctement une expérience
qui peut être longue, coûteuse, délicate,
mais quand il s'agit de résultats obtenus
par un calcul numérique,
une analyse de données, alors il ne devrait
y avoir aucune excuse,
n'importe quel chercheur du domaine devrait
pouvoir accéder aux codes,
aux données, pour vérifier lui-même
que tout est correct
et on ne mettrait pas trois ans à
se rendre compte
que l'un des articles les plus influents
du domaine est faux,
à cause d'une formule Excel mal tapée.
Ce qui, entre nous, peut arriver
à tout le monde,
d'où l'importance de tous ces systèmes
de vérification.
Pour modérer un peu cette conclusion
sur le fait que peut-être
l'austérité financière aurait été causée
par une formule Excel,
on peut quand même observer deux choses:
la première c'est que l'erreur Excel
n'est pas ce qui a le plus biaisé
les conclusions de l'article d'origine.
Quand on regarde dans le détail, on remarque
que c'est surtout
d'une part leur façon bizarre
de faire les moyennes,
et d'autre part l'exclusion apparemment
injustifiée de certaines données
qui semblaient pourtant complètement
pertinentes.
La deuxième observation c'est qu'on peut
se demander
quelle influence réelle a eu l
'article d'origine
sur le déploiement des politiques d'austérité
face à la crise.
Bien qu'il ait été mentionné plusieurs fois
comme justification
par des décideurs politiques influents,
on peut imaginer
que si l'article n'avait pas existé,
eh bien ces décideurs auraient trouvé
d'autres arguments pour justifier
leur position,
biais de confirmation, c'est classique.
Mais bon, à la fin si cette histoire
pouvait nous permettre d'avancer
vers une recherche scientifique plus
transparente et reproductible
ce serait déjà pas mal,
surtout quand des conclusions
scientifiques
sont utilisées pour guider
l'action politique.
Eh oui, toute référence à la situation
actuelle est bien sûr parfaitement voulue.
Voilà, c'est tout pour cet épisode
un peu inhabituel,
pour ceux que ça intéresse je partage
évidemment les données
et le code de l'analyse en description,
c'est la moindre des choses.
Abonnez-vous, la cloche tout ça,
pour ne rien rater,
les actualités de la chaîne c'est
sur Facebook et Twitter
et on se retrouve prochainement
pour de nouvelles vidéos.
À bientôt.
[Musique]
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -